Greeks have taken to the streets to
defend their incomes public and private
sector unions here say the bill the
government is proposing will lengthen
working hours abolish overtime pay and
curtail the right to strike
this bill essentially allows for a
13-hour day it wants workers to be on
standby whenever an employer wants
without overtime or benefits until the
day they die we want three-year sectoral
wage arrangements to come back a seven
hour day 35 hour work week and Sundays
off
in the wake of the 2009 Global financial
crisis salaries fell and taxes Rose as
governments struggled to generate
Revenue since returning to power in 2019
the new democracy government has cut
income tax and restored the minimum wage
but it hasn't filled public sector jobs
for instance it's promised to hire 8 000
doctors and nurses but this doctor says
there are currently forty thousand posts
vacant
it's a provocative bill for health
workers the government is saying two
things that we have to work overtime to
cover unfilled jobs and we won't be paid
extra for overtime we were exhausted and
overworked and people are owed thousands
of Euros in overtime what we want is
more hires
this bill stems from a 2019 European
labor directive that attempts to strike
a balance between employer flexibility
and job security unions say new
democracy got that balance wrong labor
experts say the law imposes too few
commitments on employers for example an
employer can hire someone on a trial
basis for up to a year before committing
to them and if an employee signs up for
a 40-hour week an employer need only
guarantee that they will work for a
quarter of that time Greece isn't a
developed economy in the western sense
ninety percent of employment is provided
by small businesses hiring fewer than 10
people that means employer Finance is a
frail and many workers are already doing
overtime for little or no extra pay
including on weekends that may help
explain why the government is allowing
so much employer discretion but unions
say it sets a dangerous precedent John
saroka Al Jazeera Athens
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera